hence what realizes the importance of
Carnegie Mellon and the impact it's made
especially in the transition from an
industrial economy to a new economy but
when it's also added through a hundred
years old is the culture of the city and
the College of Fine Arts the the school
of music has not only produced people
who have stayed locally to make
Pittsburgh a better place to live and do
actually improve the quality of life of
this region but they've done it
worldwide and for a hundred years you
know it is SAT right there on that hill
and it's only proper that we give it the
proper credit incisions whereas the
Canadian Roland University School music
established in 1912 will celebrate its
100th anniversary this year and located
on land donated by the city of
Pittsburgh in panther hollow the school
of music has consistently been one of
the world leaders in the education of
outstanding intellectually gifted
musicians whereas the storm of music
instrumental faculty includes 22 members
of the Pittsburgh Symphony Orchestra 15
of them old principal or co-principal
chairs well as the school of music
graduate students work as substitute
performers with the Pittsburgh Symphony
Orchestra and his members of Pittsburgh
opera opera theatre at Pittsburgh Bach
Choir Pittsburgh and the Midlands
inquire of history and whereas the
school of music has an internationally
recognized program in Euro remix
insulted thank you you explain that into
the operation when we're at the
centennial celebration
the anniversary year in the feature
concerts in Pittsburgh at the benedum
center and in new york city at carnegie
hall showcasing 191 student performers
through events illuminating the
historical perspective of the school the
celebration of the accomplishments of
the first 100 years in a toast to
anticipated future achievements now
therefore be it resolved with the
council of the city of Pittsburgh is
hereby celebrate the 100th anniversary
Renee Camile University's School of
Music and be it further resolved with
the council the city of Pittsburgh is
hereby declare februari 28th 2012 to be
her negi Mellon University School of
Music day in the city of Pittsburgh
good morning I'm Dan Martin Dean of the
College of Fine Arts I just want to
acknowledge we're very proud of the role
the arts of playing at the university
since its earliest years but more
important than that I think it's
important to also give credit to the
city of Pittsburgh which has been a big
part of our success in the development
of young artists we are extremely
fortunate to live in the city that
places such a high value on the arts and
culture and recognizes when it
contributes to the quality of life the
vitality and the health of this
community and consummate lead with all
members of council thank you for this
Proclamation very much and thank you for
providing kind of resources you do for
our young artists as they continue to
develop thank you my name is call rather
than that acting in the school of music
is probably the greatest privilege of my
life in order to say that it's a
marvelous place with modesty talented
musicians I'm going to prove that to you
were going to admit we brought a gift
for you and the person look the styling
of string quartet that would love to
play for you I a man its further morning
race I'm very proud to say that and I
was also a good sense to go to Carnegie
Mellon as a student and here and then as
a professor I'm from search for a long
long too long actually and now to be
internet is an enormous privilege
particularly in 100th anniversary here I
want to thank the
of counsel Madam President for for
taking time on a very busy schedule to
help us recognize the hundredth
anniversary and the auspicious occasion
it is I'd be remiss if I didn't point
out that there's a few of the corporate
entities that are such good citizens of
the city that are helping us this
particular year in celebrating 100th
anniversary on pnc is taking a lead role
and I'm very proud to say that UPMC and
Homer are also that's right is there the
only thing they agree on apparently is
that the school of music is very
valuable thing you can see in time work
thanks to them and also the chair of the
committee that's that's involved in
making it a special year dick engineer
Simmons and all see Cynthia treatment
with that and in recognition of the fact
that one musical Court is worth a
thousand words I just want to thank you
one more time and they're starving a
quartet
Oh
bye
you